the passengers and crew were flight PS
seven five two didn't stand a chance
minutes after takeoff the Ukranian
International Airlines flight from
Tehran to Kiev went down in a City
suburb recovery teams picked through
what's left of the plane from people's
lives most of the dead are Iranian more
than 60 Canadians were also killed many
reportedly students returning from
vacation the Boeing 737-800 was less
than four years old and had been
recently serviced video on social media
shows a light hurtling to the ground and
then a fireball Iranian officials say
there was no distress call fortunately
it didn't crash in the residential area
but the Rickard has scattered around
them to Gardens and villas within a
large radius nobody has survived a
Boryspil Airport in Kiev the arrivals
board bears the grim news this mother
and father had been waiting for their
son to arrive my son is a senior flight
attendant my daughter called at 6:15
this morning to say that in the US they
were reporting that a plane had crashed
a Ukrainian international airlines plane
Ukraine's now cancelled all flights over
Iran the country's Embassy in Tehran
initially blamed engine failure for the
crash but later removed the statement
doors for wiping Ambrosian we made a
decision to suspend all the activities
of all Ukrainian aviation companies in
Iranian airspace until the causes of
this tragedy become clear the crash
comes amid heightened tensions across
the region following a US drone strike
that killed top Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani in a sign of worsening ties
Iran Civil Aviation Authority says it
will not give the black box flight
recorder to u.s. plane maker Boeing for
analysis it's not clear which country
Iran will send the box to they pass all
the safety audits and they've had no
accidents whatsoever so there they
really do tick all the boxes is a very
very good air
but I do believe it'll be a mechanical
or possibly it may possibly be a
terrorist act it's it's too hard to tell
at this stage the crash is a major
setback for Boeing that struggle to
regain trust after the grounding of its
737 max aircraft following two fatal air
crashes within five months the Boeing
737 is one of the most popular aircraft
in the sky with a good safety record
investigators must now determine how and
why so many lives ended here
Nev Barker al-jazeera